We're back again
Hey my name is Grace Helbig, if you do not know, now you do. .
Your life will be different now.I'm here with Mamrie hart, this old song and dance
Honka, Honka. With consent. All I consent Honka Honka. like two weeks ago
I tweeted out asking you guys to send mamrie and I some of your best and worst Halloween
costumes for us to comment and review and you guys sent so many they were so
Ridiculous and I haven't looked at the screen grabs like since we wanted to make sure that this didn't fall under the cracks or fall
Through the cracks. We wanted to my crack the cracks. We wanted to indirectly roast your Halloween costume
Oh
I mean you guys roasted yourselves you dressed up like this already and we're gonna do a bunch of them here on this channel and
Then we're gonna do a bunch of them over on Mamrie's channel
so when you're done watching this video make sure you go over to Mamrie's channel to see the rest of them because they're I mean
it's just a
symphony of da fuck and
First up, what the fuck?
My husband and I went as Kronk and Yzma
I've never looked better. I don't even know what this is. I think we should Google is this an anime character? Oh,
Emperor's New Groove
I thought she was like just a very cold beans. I thought they were too weird outlets, but like
I still love this
Oh Hocus Pocus
You nailed it you guys all look fantastic and no one's wearing a wig you guys are great
I would do that every year. Where are you guys? They're in someone's mom's house who loves quilted teapots.
I taped all my friends Facebook engagements and marriages to myself and went as forever alone. That's one way to get sympathy fucked
No
Jeannie a magic carpet from Aladdin that's adorable and you're in Disney this incredible
Oh
I guess the carpet is a real good costume when you're like on the first day of your period you get the green light to
fall asleep anywhere you want. That's want I'm screaming. Raggedy Ann and hippy
We have to be in fourth or fifth grade Raggedy Ann is slightly
That is actually terrifying. Ratchety Ann. No offense, no offense. No ones going to be offended, its fourth grade
I dressed my boyfriend up as my PSL one year I like that
She added a caution hot thing that gives him a little ego boost and the confidence
Oh and the cargo shorts are the cardboard sleeve that's real cute. That is cute
You guys are cute. And I love that you took this photo at a gas station
Oh my god. Tried to beat Ozzy Osbourne in eighth grade Is that a bat, were you gonna eat the head off a bat
In eighth grade now is the time. This is me as Mona Lisa in fifth grade
We have an artful kid. Whose decision was this. Do you see the construction of this? Oh my god
It looks amazing. Happy Halloween from angry Arthur and the dancing pumpkin man. I know the dancing pumpkin man. I don't know angry Arthur Oh
Arthur the aardvark from PBS. [Mamrie interrupts] John Legend
Hmm Wow guys. Thank you so much for
Confessing all of your Halloween sins to us and also, you know some of your highest moments
They were for sure high. Come on now.
Well, thank you for watching this video, I hope it was fun for you
It was fun for us and happy Halloween to everyone out there
If you haven't listened to this week's episode and This Might Get Weird our podcast that comes out every Wednesday
Yeah, you should because it was all you know relatively Halloween themed it was great
We went and did a photo shoot at JC Penney's in full goth characters, which was an experience
We talked about on the podcast. But also we have a Patreon. patreon.com/thismightgetweird which has a lot of fun bonus stuff you should check out as well
All the links are in the description box below. Other than that I don't know
Though so I love that you're in character
I was very much the kid that whatever my costume was like I was in full character when I said trick-or-treat. Oh, yeah
Yeah, like this Spy, like we're gonna be a trash bag in the yard. Don't mind me, just a trash bag of raked leaves.Spy.